es ist das schönste gefühl der welt ist
wenn man morgens aufwacht ob sandy guckt
und sieht dass wir noch zwei stunden zu
schlafen hat ein bisschen was dann
allerdings extrem beschlossen dass in
einem dann auffällt dass nun wieder zum
rechnen dass man checkt dass man nur
noch 20 minuten hat bis dazu geht
die freunde spaß beiseite ich habe
gerade gesehen dass ich ein ticket ab
und von daher mir jeden zug aussuchen
kann
diese tickets kosten auch einfach nur
circa 4000 euro pro fahrt generell bahn
fahren einfach so scheiße teuer
ich finde die sollten halter die
produktionskosten von bernd das brot
nehmen und das mit dem bahnticket packen
war kein schwein rauch werden sagt groß
ist wenn dir das man irgendeine euro
pseudo witzigen freunde euch mal zeigen
will und ihr müsst so tun als ob sie
jetzt nicht mehr weil sie so viel kummer
bruder oder witzig oder kraft
dieser stellt
sony oder rewe zurück bruder ich kann
sich die zunft und am boden die freude
des x servers ich freue mich heute
morgen
ich wurde von trial videospot oh mein
gott halters hier
ein videospot hat mich gefragt ob ich
nicht bock hätte auf der fussball
challenge in leipzig mit einem richtigen
fußball profi eigentlich denkt das
extrem geil der einzige haken ist dass
sandra auch mit dabei ist
ich habe einfach so schätzt dass die mir
die beine weg zieht und ich einfach
sterben allerdings muss ich deswegen
jetzt erst mal nach berlin fahren
das den anschluss nach leipzig verpasst
hat ist jedoch der maske
[Musik]
ich kann nicht helfen so angekommen in
leipzig ich habe keine ahnung pendant
perfekter gehabt
was wahnsinnig sieht
[Musik]
ja okay dass man
damals einfach heute morgen schon um
fünf uhr aufgestanden weil sie schon
voll frühen lupe nehmen musste und jetzt
seit vier stunden gezählt hat was das
gerade gesagt ich bin eben in der
turnhalle eingeschlafen und dann wurde
ich von so mitarbeiter geweckt hat
gesagt ausstehen paul sind kommt sie
sind übrigens in leipzig weil wir jetzt
mit josef pausen drehen einem profi
fußballer von rb genau jetzt fertig los
moin machen recht challenges mit treuem
videos bord
ich tippe dass ich jede challenge können
wird
[Musik]
die arbeit genommen
geht wie geht in die kameras
[Musik]
toyota bist du des wahnsinns
und mainz wieder mit 21
ja ich hab noch einen gekommen wie
kooperationen zu sagen die ganze zeit um
sich zum foto einem level wie du bei mir
fällt gerade vorbei 21
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bei den nächsten beiden spiele ich 100
prozent das heißt nur auf förmlich auf
[Musik]
da musste man berühmt auch die hütchen
sandra mit der hand berührt
du musst du musst nur hören du bist bei
15 sekunden jetzt letztes unsere zukunft
läge der stopp ich hier und wir haben st
[Musik]
wenn ich eine freude bereiten
zwischenergebnis 20
also mein erster schuss ist
das heißt es reicht dass du so schießt
und der erste punkt geht und ich
zweiter entfernung und schuss ist schon
wieder der ist schon wieder
disqualifiziert das ist ja so frech
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirklich gespannt
[Applaus]
tor getroffen zwischen standen dritten
spiel zwei zu eins für mich das heißt du
kannst du doch noch gewinnen
[Musik]
ja also
knapp daneben ist auch vorbei du kannst
du dir beim abi auch gedacht nachdem
sandra figurierten und
und
da kommt sie wieder wie früher das
wiesel auf der linken außenbahn
der war klos
perfekt übrigens ich hab hier gegen die
klimaanlage geschossen und nach diesem
schuss hatte das komplette er bleibt
sich trainingsgelände zwei stunden man
keine klimaanlage bei 30 grad und sonne
sorry nochmal wird das der entscheidende
schuss sein oderwitz anschluss in rufen
du bist aber
wir sind beide nicht so gut ehrlich
gesagt so jetzt hier ball quasi in die
mitte legen und dann bis einer trifft
ich meine profis eine kamerafahrt machen
du musst auch schieße die kameraden
das bei mir auch so ein bisschen
professionell film sondern
um wunschdenken ist halten sich
unentschieden 2 2
jetzt kommt das letzte spiel
denn wir müssen uns nach hause tragen
[Musik]
je nach jeder fußballer schreck über den
er von real
mit der brust aus versehen doch das war
drei kontakte wie ich ganz ehrlich
[Musik]
ja ja
pall corporation
es sei schlicht zu toren das leben
war 3 für die bundesliga auf gar keinen
fall
nicht
wirklich eine ehre danke nochmal an
treib videospot das video trainieren
durften unsere fähigkeit unter beweis
stellen konnte ich habe auch
gerne dazu bereit
ich wollte ja mal unterschreiben einem
bundesligaverein oder michael schreiber
der extrem blöd gelaufen
na ja bei mir auch ich bin auf jeden
fall zurück in hamburg meine lieben
freunde start von meinem fenster das
restliche stück tageslicht leipzig 28
grad hamburg natürlich wieder regen von
daher bin ich an der stelle den heutigen
blog jetzt einfach beenden meine lieben
freunde ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
ich fand sehr sehr witzig in leipzig mit
josef paul sind und mit sandra wenn es
euch auch gefahren und das gern einen
daumen oder dem video der kanal und
klickt selbstständig auf die block um
weitere videos nicht zu verpassen danke
schön nochmal einen videospot dass sie
das heute alles möglich gemacht haben
und wir
[Musik]